Oh fine if it's angiography Tyrell hey I
own video games was that a good hook
no one's gonna click away from the video
now this looks [ __ ] awesome look at
this look any whoa hello as ever I came
from that train dinner atmosphere this
is [ __ ] cool ish [ __ ] look at the
graphics man I wonder if they support
oculus rift that'd be cool as [ __ ] oh my
god
what is that sound let's go over there
it's this assist a horror game that
we've all been waiting for so long
finally a decent one this is really cool
oh my god stop chill out wind oh my god
I'm pretty sure I'm not supposed to be
here okay we all keep going this is
legit giving me shivers cuz I don't know
what's going on and that scares me a lot
I feel like a [ __ ] I don't know
anything can come out and it's that
scary oh god that is really [ __ ]
scary don't like this why did can the
beautiful ladies boys come back please
and not the silent I swear someone is
looking at me am i naked dammit I don't
even know how this looks fantastic oh
great
oh oh what video are you coming to me
[Music]
like you guys give me that
that'll be maybe don't want to lead you
on or anything just want to find out how
to continue playing video games that's
all I want in life
this is what's talking to me
Jesus faces inside you hi sis
Oh God questions you live in a cave
seriously that's really cool the [ __ ] is
going on oh my god oh my god I'm [ __ ]
oh ah that
calm down breasts it's a game the end
the only thing I saw was a flash my fly
sufferable burning light the pain
ripping apart my body where where is it
I felt like tearing out of my souls
after a while I was nobody nothing light
went out and I vanished I wonder if
we're the months and it seems like a
peasant
having
what is going on I'm welcoming the end
I'd be a short game but welcoming oh we
got something we got something
what have we got though a tent it's a
light inside man hello is anybody
Christy all right has to go and everyone
I am right behind you
please don't I don't know what I feel
about this man really great tension so
far I'm I'm really immersed they're
doing a good job looking forward to play
more and see see how it turns out I
don't know what do you think I don't
know why you keep thinking I can hear
you it's kind of cute though why the
loading screen is always so [ __ ]
awkward so anyway how are you doing oh
that's too bad
it's back to us here oh that was quick
act have you ever tried to hold on to
your humanity we are they
and you couldn't really know that
nuisance
[Music]
leaving you two rocks and the dog
Oh problem is darkness
[Music]
all right I hope
I [ __ ] love this look at the design
and the atmosphere you feel it so
[ __ ] cool
survival inform everyone shift focus red
flashlight map compass to jump off to
squeeze through to get access
okay seems pretty simple it's so there's
my comp ass that's good
oh my god
beautiful stunning look at it it's hard
we got here it's at a geyser yes must be
a geyser I've seen quite a few guys and
so what that [ __ ] is that I have a
feeling I should not set my toys in
there but you know what life is life the
moment I heard about the incident I was
in the area so I reported to the unit
myself to be automatically assigned to
the case
I arrived at of each High on February
the 19th a couple of days before the
Institute's rescue while waiting for
them I started asking around to see if
anyone from among the locals knew
anything about the incident one of them
said he had a hunting cabin in the
search engine and knew the area very
well I decided to use it when the rescue
team finally arrives I explained to them
what the unit's role was in this mission
and that all discoveries or observations
should be brought to my attention before
anyone elses we establish priorities
check the equipment and set off right
away it was not until February the 26th
we found the tent that I believe
belonged to the students initial
findings showed that the people in the
tent cut its sidewall and for some
reason tried to escape from it in panic
great the tracks in the snow led to a
forest two kilometer and a half away but
the trail went cold after 500 metres and
we had to carefully search the entire
area this was not a place of any average
incident we got that shivers crawling
all over our bodies because of the
atmosphere surrounding us I was
convinced that something more than just
an accident had occurred here I had the
feeling we were dealing with something
unnatural all right all right nothing
unnatural with their flying Jennifers
what's the [ __ ] what they [ __ ]
what what is going on I mean what the
hell is going on what you can't just
kill me
all right fine I'll go out sorry I
didn't know this was your turf [ __ ]
out calm the [ __ ] down
oh that's what happened well that's
probably not good to be inside that's
what she said am i right am i right oh
he's going there all right that is did
it did it did it dead dead dead that is
I'm going I know nobody's no one I
checked that justify whichever way the
wind was move where are you going buddy
wait up wait up buddy buddy
that [ __ ] runs that's important Gump
[ __ ] going on here we're gonna follow
him don't worry it's gonna be okay it's
really exciting I think it's gonna be
like a squeak squeak squeeze through
there
creak kind of situation my stamina is so
bad Suze why in every horror game ever
actually it's pretty realistic if I ran
I probably wouldn't last very long I
probably would have died before any of
this even happen did that once
thank God for videogames now we don't
know where that thing went we don't know
why we're following it but it's pretty
much all the direction we got em oh [ __ ]
it's getting really dark really fast
what is that
so creepy shush shush you go away I
don't like you
red means bad my mom told me that by
going I'm so lost other Eddie's gone I
hear some wing-flapping
is that you no big deal no big deal it
out it reminds me truth what is that oh
my god no ah whoo-hoo you built a church
there huh it's you hey buddy what are
you do you want to go there
I'll get their syringe the [ __ ] is going
on
why is everyone going there what is
happening up in the air I don't know I
don't I don't think I want to know they
just go home have a kid catch it
sponsored the green tea flavor it's stop
please what the [ __ ] is going on I'm not
going to say hi to him it is nothing
racist it's just
oh my god
where the [ __ ] did he go
when in fact there you go when they're
[ __ ] ending up whoa oh no I was
getting on this way anyway
all right see you later see you later
[Music]
where is he I swear he was walking
towards me check it cat cat okay okay
okay we're going this way we got this
roads you got it the back sorry for
yelling I'm just really [ __ ] exciting
Jesus Christ oh he's following me [ __ ]
you
Bezier is different for so many of them
now
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
Oh
hello I think we're fine
I think we're fine oh okay we're fine
we're fine we're fine we're fine
I never said I feel the hundred percent
nurse in my I almost said balls that
would have been inappropriate I think
you were what was that
don't don't do whatever that was don't
like it not a big fan I'm not a fan I
hear you I hear stuff don't like stuff
stuff is bad
oh god what that is also bad probably
all right well you know I was gonna go
this way anyway it's it's fine actually
I don't know why I went here is stupid
really dumb oh I'm just a hiker from
from Sweden I got lost in the fjords
there's no few words in Sweden I don't
know why I keep saying that it's camera
but it is Appa
let's see Arabs Appa farm a lot can we
get your candy another reform bars up
ammeter break that for a helluva Telugu
Marigny night no you have to go faster
how many I'll have a lot of time left
you have to hurry find a way find me God
you sound like a desperate tumbler [ __ ]
Jesus cries I'm doing what I can
mustard gas god damn you what do you
want from me
now I'm slower than ever when he says be
hurry oh my god alright fine fine fine
oh my god sound like a [ __ ] crazy
ex-girlfriend or some [ __ ]
I did a you know I ran upstairs for you
what do you white that's a commitment
that's a huge commitment I would be
proud of myself I am it what is this
calm down where's the church I'm so lost
hello this way I suppose I guess
perfectly honest I don't know why anyone
thought I knew where I was going
this looks like a dead end didn't it did
we cross that oh yeah we did in me all
right all right all right
it's okay it's okay sometimes you make
the wrong mistakes in life and wait you
make the right whatever shut up we're
doing we're go in the mountain passage
I'm not a little [ __ ]
and this does not look right
oh I heard the bells oh my god
where is it there it is there this oh my
god oh my god I don't like this
are there more buildings not a situation
how do we get there oh my god I hear
something
I don't know why I would want to do that
how do I get up there
this [ __ ] storm come calm down but
god yes we did a high five bro I don't
know if it's a good thing or a bad
mustard get damn you Hitler [ __ ] hell
how do we get in hit him again I want to
get in get in the [ __ ] spread down
okay oh my god
all right let me go inside
wherever the entrance is there it is
both funny feet done cm defeated oh my
god he's never gonna sleep now stop stop
don't drink it I knew this would happen
this has been a great failure let's keep
playing a little bit oh god what
happened okay so now what
you can't just my god maybe I'm not
supposed to go in here maybe this was
just a giant big this direction the
mustard gas is gone
I got that going for me okay we go up in
this way got it
I'm gonna play a lot more and then
hopefully I won't die from this [ __ ]
werewolf piece of [ __ ] somewhere that if
I stop now we won't save oh god I hear
noises any base if the base gets dropped
in a horror game you know you're fun
it's just it's just man that's just a
science yo I'm cold I'm hit with the
kids god damn it I'm slow thank you now
where's that werewolf I wanted to eat me
if you know what I mean
that was some dark for a [ __ ]
[Music]
it's coming from here I think oh my god
seriously how's my face that just melt
that off in this blizzard
okay this yeah this looks safe why not
walk on this yeah that looks safe - why
not know 100% oh great now accuse our
crashing skills that I've so long oh no
way never mind take the safe route while
don't we
oh god it's been a good life but I'm
tired of this pariah [ __ ]
it's a coordinates 6830 point worth
remember that for me bros because I'll
probably forget it do we have that in or
do that in our compass no I don't think
so right we go here oh great
we felt we felt through fantastic press
if we're horror stuff and enjoyed this
now's your chance leave a like and
really show your support on this video I
really appreciate it cuz it does make a
difference I had a lot of fun playing I
would love to explore more of this video
so I'll see you in the next one and as
always stay awesome press